[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
haití pasa días terribles más de 500.000
personas necesitan de manera urgente
ayuda humanitaria tras el terremoto de
magnitud 7.2 y el posterior paso de la
tormenta tropical grave que dejaron
pueblos enteros destruidos miles de
personas están sin techo ni comida y los
daños a la infraestructura dificultan la
llegada de la asistencia internacional
el 3 de septiembre continuará en mexico
el diálogo entre las delegaciones de
nicolás maduro y de juan guaidó con
miras a ponerle fin a la crisis que
atraviesa venezuela aunque no se conocen
los avances concretos de la primera
sesión ya se registran algunos cambios
en la nación suramericana que les
contamos en esta emisión
y siete de cada diez personas en
argentina tiene sobrepeso y durante años
algunas organizaciones denuncian que la
ropa ha sido un elemento de
discriminación por esto nació la ley de
talles para medir cómo son en verdad los
cuerpos de los argentinos y nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- nos trae
la historia
y vamos de inmediato a haití porque
miles de personas siguen durmiendo a la
intemperie después del terremoto de
magnitud 7.2 y el posterior paso de la
tormenta tropical grace el acceso a las
zonas más afectadas es difícil debido a
los daños en la infraestructura e
incluso algunas ong denuncian que las
pandillas impiden su paso la
desesperación de los ciudadanos por
obtener ayuda enviada desde otros países
ha hecho que se registren algunos
desórdenes veamos más en el siguiente
informe
el hambre no de esperanza
y en las zonas más afectadas por el
terremoto de magnitud de 7,2 en haití
hacer fila por un pan cuesta
se registraron algunos desórdenes
durante la entrega de las ayudas del
programa mundial de alimentos que fueron
contenidos por las fuerzas policiales
sin necesidad de uso de la fuerza
pero la atención en el sur del país
crece pues hay más de 500 mil personas
esperando la asistencia internacional
que demora debido al daño de las
infraestructuras y lo que hay no es
suficiente
sólo hay comida para 3000 personas 600
familias en general sólo las cabezas de
familia o las mujeres vienen a recibirla
afortunadamente los voluntarios
haitianos de la cruz roja y otras ong
nos están ayudando a través de eso entre
locales los haitianos sobreviven en
campamentos improvisados que además
tuvieron que desarmar para protegerse de
las inclementes lluvias de grace
un nuevo azote de la naturaleza
el huracán matthew destruyó mi casa la
reconstruir y fue destruida de nuevo mi
esposo no ha podido trabajar desde hace
ocho meses y lo peor es que tengo ocho
hijos las cosas no están bien en mi
comunidad
en 2016 haití sufrió el embate del
huracán matthew más de 1000 personas
fallecieron
en ese entonces la nación aún no se
recuperaba del terremoto de 2010 que
dejó más de 300.000 fallecidos por su
ubicación haití es muy vulnerable a los
desastres naturales en pleno mar caribe
está en el camino de las tormentas
tropicales y de los huracanes además
está cerca de la intersección de dos
placas tectónicas la de norteamérica y
la del caribe que se mueven
constantemente causando sismos haití fue
el primer país latinoamericano en
independizarse de sus colonizadores para
hacerlo tuvo que pagar grandes
cantidades de dinero a francia por lo
que nació como una nación soberana con
una inmensa deuda desde entonces ha
atravesado varias crisis políticas que
sumadas a la corrupción el analfabetismo
y las precarias condiciones de salud
hacen de haití el país más pobre de
américa en perú el canciller héctor
béjar renunció apenas 19 días después de
asumir en el cargo el exguerrillero de
85 años se vio envuelto en una polémica
por la divulgación de un vídeo en el que
acusa a la marina de guerra de haber
iniciado el terror en el país
sudamericano en lugar del grupo sendero
luminoso la semana anterior se había
difundido otro fragmento de una charla
suya en internet en la que afirmó que
esa guerrilla había sido una creación de
la cia estadounidense
y seguimos en venezuela donde empiezan a
haber movimientos tras la primera sesión
de diálogos entre las delegaciones del
gobierno de nicolás maduro y de la
oposición encabezada por juan guaidó en
mexico el líder chavista liberó a un
preso político e hizo modificaciones en
su gabinete removió a jorge arreaza de
la cancillería y nombró a félix
plascencia el ex embajador venezolano en
china
la ong foro penal pidió que los 266
presos políticos que hay en venezuela no
sean utilizados como divisa en el
diálogo luego de que el ex diputado
opositor freddy guevara fuera liberado
en el marco del inicio de las
contrataciones en ciudad de méxico entre
la oposición y el gobierno de venezuela
el presidente dijo que estaba dispuesto
a permitir que llevara acusado de
colaborar con supuestos paramilitares
viaje a territorio mexicano para
participar en las conversaciones que se
reanudarán el 3 de septiembre mientras
que pidió a la oposición dejar de
utilizar a la economía como un arma no
puede más nunca utilizarse a la economía
como centro de batalla para la política
que cada quien postula libremente pero
no utilice la economía para sabotear la
los resultados concretos de la primera
sesión de las negociaciones mediadas por
noruega no se conocen aún pero el
chavismo pide que se levanten las
sanciones impuestas por eeuu la unión
europea y otros países al gobierno de
maduro y sus allegados y que se renuncia
a la violencia y a la conspiración
mientras la oposición exige elecciones
libres transparentes y justas la
liberación de todos los presos políticos
y la entrada de ayuda humanitaria este
es el quinto intento de diálogo entre
maduro y diferentes sectores de la
oposición desde la muerte de hugo chávez
en 2013 los anteriores han sido
infructuosos
vamos a colombia donde la alcaldesa de
la capital bogotá claudia lópez desató
una polémica al anunciar la creación de
un comando especial entre las
autoridades migratorias y la policía
para combatir a la delincuencia por
parte de extranjeros
aprovechando el estatuto migratorio de
venezolanos del presidente iván duque
para regularizar a los migrantes de la
nación vecina la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos expresó su
preocupación por la medida y dijo que
incentiva a la xenofobia desde la
alcaldía se apresuraron a explicar que
se trataba de acciones coordinadas para
lograr el registro de los migrantes con
el fin de hacerles llegar ayudas además
de identificar quienes cometen los
delitos
y nuestra siguiente parada es en el sur
del continente en argentina donde se
está realizando un estudio para conocer
los verdaderos tamaños y formas de los
cuerpos de los ciudadanos con el fin de
adecuar los talles de la ropa a las
formas reales de los argentinos ese
estudio será la base de un nuevo sistema
unificado de tallas en total se van a
medir a unas 14 mil personas entre
hombres y mujeres pero no se trata solo
de detalles de ropa como nos da cuenta
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires-
natalio con
esta imagen es generada por un escáner
que se está utilizando para dar con las
características corporales de la
población argentina y listo puedes pasar
al escáner cuando una persona ingresa
aquí se pone en esta posición tiene que
ingresar sin ropa con ropa interior para
que la máquina funcione bien la máquina
entonces toma 400 medidas de todo su
cuerpo y esas medidas luego se
incorporan en una gran base de datos
desde 2015 este equipo viene midiendo
cuerpos de argentinas y argentinos como
parte de un estudio antropométrico hoy
además de otros usos sus resultados
servirán establecer un sistema único de
detalles de prendas de vestir tal como
dispone una ley del año 2019 todavía no
se definieron cuáles van a ser las
medidas pero lo que sí ya se sabe es que
un talle 40 o un talle 42 va a tener la
misma medida en todas las marcas karina
lorenzo y sus colegas ya realizaron en
todo el país una buena parte de la cerca
de 14.000 mediciones que deben completar
todavía les faltan unas 6 mil 500
personas que deben tener medidas para
dentro de unos 9 meses según la ley una
vez que se establezca el nuevo sistema
de talles serán lugares como este uno de
los principales puntos de venta de ropa
por mayor y menor de la ciudad de buenos
aires donde deberá implementarse
una vez esto ya xabi alonso tiene su
oficina en esta zona fabrica y vende
ropa deportiva en talles inclusivos y
forma parte de él y voy a argentina una
ong que fue impulsora de la ley de
talles hay un sistema que de alguna
forma es funcionar lo que nosotros
llamamos la cultura de la delgadez es la
única forma de pre existir y ser feliz
en este mundo haciendo flaco entonces
bueno eso es lo que tenemos que
visibilizar en ese contexto la nueva ley
prevé realizar campañas de difusión
sobre diversidad corporal para que la
sociedad tome conciencia acerca de este
tema y volviendo a los talles siguen la
norma no obligará a los vendedores a
ofrecer un número mínimo de tamaños si
ayudará a que las prendas de un talle
sean consistentes y que la ropa sea
acorde a los cuerpos de la mayoría de
los habitantes del país
y me despido en perú donde nació la
mejor chef del mundo se llama piel leon
y es propietaria de un restaurante
ubicado en lima y fue reconocida como la
mejor chef por la organización the world
with the best restaurants ya es la
primera peruana en conseguir esta
distinción ir a su restaurante es una
experiencia de siete tiempos que cuesta
alrededor de 80 dólares la cocinera de
34 años ya había sido nombrada en 2018
como la mejor chef de latinoamérica por
la misma organización nuestro
corresponsal en la capital peruana
francisco zacarías habló con ella somos
un restaurante relativamente nuevo que
nosotros este mes cumplimos tres años y
si al inicio fue fue un golpe duro pero
creo que es satisfactorio porque porque
nos puso en plataforma y se pudo ver el
trabajo que veníamos haciendo entonces
como equipo es muy contentos eso nos
motivó definitivamente a seguir
trabajando a seguir empujando a ser más
creativos
a compartir más y creo que eso como
equipo nos unió mucho más no pero la
idea es esa no mostrar nuestros sabores
nuestros productos
profundos del perú desde todas las
regiones
pero siempre dando este giro esta
sorpresa
y no presentarla de repente de una
manera tradicional
en eso nos concentramos y ahí ahí se
incluye la parte creativa pues no aquí
todo el equipo de cocina participa todo
el mundo da ideas todo uno participa y
creo que creamos algo algo bonito no
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas hoy natalia cabrera
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas en la producción estuvo
jennifer guevara sigan con más en france
[Música]
versalles